bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans les 7 8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine foot
us l'équipe des templiers d'elancourt
débute sa saison par une victoire
les élans courtois se sont imposés 29 à
13 contre les vikings de villeneuve
d'ascq à l'occasion de la première
journée de deuxième division
le résumé de la partie a su dans cette
édition unss les championnats de france
cross country est organisée ce vendredi
samedi plus de 2000 jeunes représentant
270 établissements de toute la france se
sont retrouvés sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines pour
participer à la compétition vous
entendrez dans quelques instants l'une
des ambassadrices muriel hurtis ancienne
championne de ce prix d'offre du sprint
français box marvin petit s'est imposé
ce samedi au palais des sports marcel
cerdan de levallois perret contre le
mexicain juan au courant grâce à un
chaos septième ronde
nous recevrons dans ce magazine son
coach tandis farruggia pour décrypter
cette performance on ouvre à présent
notre page résultats
mais avant de développer ces titres nous
allons revenir sur la vague deux fois
que je de froid qui persévère en ce
moment sur la région parisienne et qui a
des conséquences sur l'organisation des
matches dans les yvelines plusieurs
rencontres de football ont été annulées
à cause de terrain gelé en excellence
maurepas n'a pas pu jouer ce week-end
contre le pec trap a vu également son
rendez vous annulé contre l'équipe ii
des gobelins dans le championnat de ph
le stade gilbert chant cinq étaient
impraticables selon les autorités le
match versailles lilas comptant pour la
13e journée de dh a lui aussi était
déplacée à une date ultérieure du côté
du rugby toutes les rencontres ont été
reportées plaisir n'a pas pu jouer
contre le havre et versailles rester au
chaud au lieu de jouer contre bagneux
fédérations communiquerons dans les
prochains jours les dates des reports
eux ont affronté le froid ce week-end en
football américain les templiers
d'elancourt en débuter le championnat de
2e division
ce samedi à domicile au complexe sportif
europe pour ce premier match de la
saison les élans courtois n'ont pas fait
de détails en terrassant les vikings de
villeneuve d'ascq le score est sans
appel 29 à 13 nicolas d'andrea pour les
images premier match de la saison ce
samedi 21 janvier pour les templiers
d'elancourt rétrogradé en deuxième
division cette saison
les élans courtois recevez les vikings
de villeneuve d'ascq sous une
température glaciale
le match débute mal pour les rouges avec
deux touchdown encaissés dans le premier
quart temps on a eu un peu de mal à se
mettre dans le match au début il est
normal parce qu'on a plein de nouveaux
nouveaux joueurs c'est pas la même
intensité
c'est pas le même c'est pas même chose
que les matches de pré saison les
entraînements donc de consommer damballa
on était bien lancée on a réussi à
trouver un petit rythme après avoir
laissé passer le blizzard les templiers
se reprennent et marc 29.3 quart temps
devant leur public
score final 29 à 13
le but c'était de réussir à enchaîner
les actions pour créer des drive avec la
dynamique créé un élan pour pouvoir
utiliser notre physique enchaîné vis des
actions qu'ils aient pas le temps de se
remettre en place et qu'il soit fatigué
rapidement et on a vu qu'un pansement
monde a réussi à se mettre en route il
n'arrivait plus à tenir le rythme et à
partir de là on a réussi à prendre la
mesure et on après cette première
journée les templiers sont deuxièmes du
championnat avec le même nombre de
points que les caïmans du mans mais le
directeur sportif des templiers veut que
son équipe continue à progresser pour
espérer remonter en première division dc
de saison continue continue de gagner et
continuer on a commencé avec un mage
noir enchaîné sur un deuxième faut
confirmer et puis chaque match un match
à la fois c'est pas parce qu'on a gagné
ce match au lagon gagnera jeu suivant et
c'est pas parce que parce qu'on gagne le
suivant qu'on gagnera après serena
williams est acquis il faut continuer de
travailler rien lâcher prochain match
dimanche 29 janvier à 14 heures sur le
terrain des corsaires d'evry on continue
par les championnats de france unss de
france de cross country unss plus de
2000 jeunes représentant 270
établissements de toute la france sont
retrouvés sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines ce vendredi et ce
samedi pour participer à la compétition
en fonction des catégories la distance
des parcours variés entre 3 km pour les
minimes et 5 km pour les juniors on
écoute la sprinteuse française muriel
hurtis qui avait été championne de
france unss sur le 150 m en 1997 elle
est aujourd'hui ambassadrice de
l'événement c'est une très belle
compétition où on retrouve un petit peu
l'esprit à la fois d'equipe l'esprit
sportif puisqu'il ya un effort physique
e
c'est là sur bonal france donc ils ont
travaillé dur pour arriver jusqu'ici et
de voir moi tous ces jeunes ils sont
plus de 2000 présent pour retrouver
l'ensemble des résultats vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche juste en bas à l'écran on
ouvre une page football on le disait
précédemment en promotion d'honneur
certains matchs ont été reportés à ce
week-end trappes n'a pas joué l'équipe
de football trappistes reste donc à la
huitième place du classement avec un
bilan de 5 victoires 4 nuls et 2
défaites
ils sont actuellement à six points de la
première place détenue par courbevoie
avec un match en moins
la montée est donc envisageable cette
saison et le président de l'ess trappe
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'a bien
compris il était au micro de terrifier
78 je crois qu'en 14 ans c'est la
première fois qu'on a cette qualité dans
le travail cette qualité dans dans ce
qu'ils produisent aux entraînements je
rappelle qu'ils font trois entraînements
par semaine après 20 heures
on imagine par les températures
actuelles donc c'est vraiment un travail
remarquable qui est fait et concernant
les résultats on a donc un match de
retard donc c'est on peut pas trop se
déterminer pour le moment mais on est en
bonne voie pour approcher les 3
premières places à moi présent du vendée
globe no 2 heavy noah éric bellion et
louis burton vont entrer dans le sprint
final il remonte en ce moment
l'atlantique pour rentrer aux sables
d'olonne après plus de soixante dix sept
jours de course le versailles et bellion
est toujours 9e sur son imoca comme un
seul homme
malgré des vents très faibles on regarde
la séquence il a un rôle qu'il a
enregistré ce week-end le pire cauchemar
humain c'est ce que je vis en ce moment
c'est pas dur il ya pas de voir les
voiles battre comme ça c'est horrible
c'est horrible donc on est entouré des
grands ils prennent le vent donc on
attend par là et je peux vous dire
nerveusement c'est c'est vraiment
terrible parce que on a les voiles qui
bat rien faire
de son côté laurent politain louis
burton est toujours bien ancrée à la 7e
place du classement sur ce tour du monde
mais il est premier dans la catégorie
des bateaux des bateaux non l'équipe et
de feuilles des ailes profil et qui
permet d'aller plus vite le skipper et
au large du cap-vert nous a enregistré
cette séquence ce week end
bonjour à tous bienvenue à bord de
bureau vallée on est aux soixante et
onzième jour de course et tout va bien
on glisse 15 noeuds dans l'alizé bientôt
l'équateur et voilà hâte de vous
retrouver et sailor maintenant de
l'instant lessive à bord de bureau
vallée quant à la pudeur la plus
élémentaire dois-je pour les besoins de
la cause publicitaires les vulgaires
avec cooking et dans quelle position
louis burton devra patienter au moins
trois semaines avant de prendre une
vraie douche dans une salle de bain il
devrait arriver avant à la mi-février en
taekwondo nisrine et bars 13 ans n'en
finit plus de surprendre après avoir
conquis un titre de champion de france
cadet tes avoir intégré l'équipe de
france pour les championnats d'europe la
jeune trappistes qui mesure près d'un
mètre 70 va participer à un open à las
vegas le 31 janvier prochain sur
l'objectif tenter de remporter des
points de classement pour se qualifier
pour les championnats du monde qui se
dérouleront en fin d'année le président
de l'école de taekwondo de trappes
jonathan sort elle était au micro d'
alice deschamps l'a ses chances
maintenant
il ya toujours du travail on n'a pas la
prétention d'être les meilleurs mais en
tout cas aller c'est une bosseuse est
vraiment là fait le maximum d'efforts
pour être au niveau de cette compétition
et c'est vrai qu'elle est très très
grande qu'elle a une grande allonge ce
qui lui permet voilà des coups de pied
que je serai pas forcément capables de
donner moi même du fait de ma taille et
du coup bah c'est moi c'est vrai que
c'est plutôt un atout mais on reste dans
les sports de combat en boxe marvin
petit s'est imposé à ce samedi au palais
des sports marcel cerdan de levallois
perret contre le mexicain juan okura
grâce un ko au septième ronde pour
décrypter cette performance nous
recevons le coach des marine petit temps
guy farrugia qui est avec nous du coup
sur ce plateau
bonsoir tanguy alors on va tout de suite
parlé de cette performance marvin petit
c'était exceptionnel ce qu'il a fait ce
samedi elle est quasi parfaite peut-être
progrès marine pâtit quasi parfaite non
il ya toujours faso il ya toujours
matière à progresser
maintenant c'est vrai que marvin a
retrouvé la motivation et je pense qu'il
va être champion d'europe et même
peut-être au dessus d'ici quelques mois
vous sentez qu'il a vraiment pris une
nouvelle dimension sur ces dernières sur
ces derniers mois ces derniers jours
peut-être même on a fait une préparation
avec bauxite à ses entraîneurs en 95 et
qui a fait une vraie préparation de boxe
qui a fait qui a ramené un truc un plus
à marvin et oui ça va on a retrouvé
marvin c'est quoi c'est plus sa
motivation parce que bon joël jallet
depuis l'âge de 12 ans on connaît il
connaît mes entraînements il faut qu'il
retrouve la motivation il a fait des
entraînements qui sont nouveaux ça
change
et puis il a préparé un bob c'est un
vrai préparateur physique
mais qu'est ce qui fait la différence
sur ce combat contre contre le mexicain
c'est peut-être sa fougue
c'est justement on retrouve sa fougue et
voilà c'est ça qu'on avait perdu sur ses
derniers combats on retrouve ça fout on
trouve la motivation il envie de gagner
il a envie de ramener des titres
il a compris qu'il n'était pas loin des
titres donc il veut les ramener
voilà alors ce combat était programmé à
la dernière minute marvin petit devra
affronter à la base 100 à l'art pour le
titre de l'union européenne finalement
ce combat n'a pas eu lieu il ya déclaré
forfait deux jours avant l'événement est
ce que vous avez à mot à dire à santana
si nous écoute à son temps là j'aimerais
bien qu'ils nous écoutent
c'est clair que c'est pas bien voilà on
sait pas la vérité maintenant ça serait
clair que ce combat là j'aimerais bien
qu'ils se fassent sans lui si on doit le
rencontrer ce sera pour un titre au
dessus parce que j'aime pas les forfait
au dernier moment ça manque de respect
pour les athlètes
marvin il peut rebondir après cet échec
face à ce forfait
il va rebondir il va rebondir sur
l'engouement mondial au niveau mondial
moblin et on va voir
merci à vous tous guy farrugia et on
espère que marvin petit sera champion
d'europe dans les prochaines semaines on
passe maintenant au cyclisme sur piste
la troisième manche de la coupe d'hiver
était organisée par le csm clamart ce
samedi au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
au total 152 cyclistes ont participé à
cette manche parmi eux quentin lafargue
le champion d'europe du kilomètre et le
riz berton vice championne de france de
l'omnium
au programme des courses aux points des
courses à l'américaine et de la vitesse
rendez vous le 4 février pour la
quatrième manche de cette coupe d'hiver
les coureurs qui totaliseront le plus
haut point seront qualifiés pour la
grande finale le 25 février prochain
toujours au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines handball vous
le savez tous le mondial masculin est
organisée en ce moment en france les
experts qui comptent dans leurs rangs le
versailles et valentin porte n'ont pas
fait de détail depuis le début de la
compétition ils ont fait un sans faute
le dernier en date c'était contre
l'islande à lille 31 à 25
l'arrière évinois s'est illustré pendant
la partie devant plus de 28000 à
spectateurs en muselant les attaquants
adverses en marquant deux buts pendant
la partie prochain match pour valentin
porte et les experts ce mardi à 18h
contre la suède en quart de finale on
continue de parler de handball dans
notre agenda du jour
on ouvre donc cet agenda part du
handball les équipes de france de
gendarmerie de la discipline seront à
saint quentin en yvelines cette semaine
pour la deuxième année consécutive et 30
joueurs et joueuses se sont affrontées
ce jeudi 26 janvier à partir de 19
heures au complexe sportif pierre de
coubertin les équipes seniors de
montigny-le-bretonneux
on écoute le président du club
christophe reding les gens dorment là
ils sont ils sont candidats sélectionnés
dans leur équipe nationale mais dans il
évolue également dans des clubs pour
certains en d2 nationale 1 et nationale
2 donc c'est vraiment c'est largement au
dessus de notre niveau
donc c'est sûr pour nous on n'est pas là
pour faire un résultat loin de là mais
c'est le plaisir en tout cas de
rencontrer une équipe assez forte au
niveau féminin ce sont également des
joueuses qui évoluent dans des clubs sur
après du n 1 n 1 des 2 généralement
c'est ça si vous voulez assister aux
deux rencontres montini contre la
gendarmerie nationale l'entrée est
gratuite
c'est la fin de ce statut de sport merci
d'avoir suivi je vous retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive
[Musique]